foreign
if you need
help
hey oh can I uh help you with that sir
you think I don't know how to cut rope
no it's just we usually do that for you
do you think I'm going to cut myself and
bleed all over your floor and sue you
no then I don't need your help
have an excellent day
idiot
did you um
find everything you're looking for today
yes
good
uh your total is 347. you charged me for
six feet of rope oh yes it's 99 cents a
yard
I didn't get two yards I got five feet
yeah we we don't charge by the foot we
charge by the yard 99 cents a yard is 33
cents a foot times five that's 165. you
charged me a dollar ninety eight
you're good at math
um no I know but I can't put it into the
computer the way that you just said the
whole kind of computer can't do simple
math
can I speak to your manager is that
lunch
well anyone cares about these days this
Legend is there anyone else in charge
not the assistant manager yes I'd like
the assistant manager
Hey Taylor
Taylor the front register what's up oh
hey Taylor
this is the assistant manager how old is
she shouldn't you be in gym class sorry
what here I got some change let me cover
that extra 33 cents for you sir I do not
want your 33 cents and this is not about
33 cents this is about the fact that I
got five feet of rope because I want
five feet of rope and I shouldn't have
to pay for six feet of rope if I don't
want six feet
did you want another foot of rope
[Music]
all right
thank you foreign
[Music]
oh my God yeah not again
hmm
[Music]
can this be
um
[Music]
hey what the hell that's mine
it belongs in the bike rack but it's
only gone half a minute
next time I'll lock it up in the lost
and found
yeah
not on the mirror
hey yeah though
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
foreign
don't you dare let that little rat dog
piss on my walkway again I know it was
you ignore him Prince he's a nasty
bitter old man and he has no idea who's
doing that well it was one of you
until that useless boyfriend of yours to
stop stretching his groin in public
it's like a 14 year
for God's sakes
[Music]
go on get out of here
foreign
what's all this uh well retirement kick
I guess call it what you like have fun
doing what well have fun with the rest
of your life we wanted to you know
celebrate yes well no give me a nice
send-off
nice
come on Otto you're the one who decided
to leave and you did get a nice
severance package
you took me off operations
you cut back on my hours you made Terry
who I trained my supervisor
Terry who can barely figure out what
year it is without his phone so yes I
took the severance package
sorry you see it that way we all had to
adjust after the merger
but you've been quite an asset to this
company over the years so you have
reliable as hell we're gonna miss those
schedules of yours foreign
[Music]
want a piece of your face
who's hungry
look at this
hey hey right no no no hey you cannot
use this road without a permit I'm not
parking I just dropped off a package
well not the scientists to say anything
about packages does it it says permits
and you don't have one this is not a
through Street
have a nice day sir every time you come
in here
can't park in front of their home
you know the other guys don't do this
the guys with the white trucks how come
it's always you brown guys
and racially
hello oh hi sorry can you hear me yes
it's Susan Susan who and I have great
news about your health insurance oh no
no no robot robot robot